jetzt kommen noch neue leute ich bin
heute in der nähe von dortmund und heute
gibt es wieder eine premiere leute jetzt
synthetisch angesehen wir testen heute
ein auto und es ist zum ersten mal ein
auto von um zuschauer und zwar ein
nissan gt r
[Musik]
oder das ist nix autors tatsächlich
nicht angst vor erdrutsch oder ähnlichen
sache oder verstecken hierunter fallen
würden und könnten sollen du schutz der
identität so ein bisschen
deswegen der helm schwarz damit ihr euch
nicht wundert das ist das ist der grund
der störung und jetzt wurde es oft nicht
merklich den kopf her was andere leute
war das ist schon richtig in your face
das ist richtig in your face kannst ja
mal sagen wie du auf den wagen genau
gekommen bist gt r ist ja schon exotisch
also ich habe auch überlegt ob ich mir
eine nacht hole oder an gt r
und da ich schon immer ein fast and the
furious pending und auch viel mit autos
macht juni feierlich zum tune ist das
auto halt viel besser als ein audi a8
turbolader biturbo das ding geht halt
die hölle und das ist ja auch er seine
kranke maschine
das ist 2017 dabei hast du gemeint 570
ps v6 biturbo und halt einfach eine
absolute tuning legende auch der kanzel
drauf kloppen hatte willst dass der blog
ist glaube ich sehr haltbar
ja ja ja ein kraft kraft also muss sagen
also wenn ich dieses auto vielleicht
auch die ganze zeit
dieses betrifft sagen immer genau wie
man mir was ein arsch kommen leute und
vor allem noch echte abgasrohr
heutzutage auch relativ selten erfüllt
den punkt auch wir fragte also richtig
guck mal hier so haben wir hinten drauf
285 geht eigentlich noch aber auch
allradlern ja gerade eben schon gemeinde
wenig hat sich hier einfach markiert
jedoch ist reserviert
[Musik]
ja kennt bild bei tci matsumoto größte
heraus an den ton an der stelle
ich muss sagen an sich fire ist
eigentlich kein sechser mehr als v6 von
der laufkultur hat ab jetzt formieren
reihensechser tatsächlich sehr gern aber
der ist halt der kann vw das dass wir
dann alles sein sechszylinder ist er mit
3,8 nicht recht groß und dann noch mit
zwei turboladern gebogen das ding ist
ein beschleunigungs monster geil digger
2,8 ist der angegeben sehr genau
2,2 koffer und ich weiß das sag ich habe
vorne losfahren leute früher aber ist
immer so wenn man so mit seinen kumpels
gerät hat war welches auto ist so ein
schneller beschleunigen war der gt-r
immer so der der alle nass gemacht hat
da drauf gut sagen du bist erst mal eine
runde über den lichtern und so leute ihr
seht direkt mich am steuer denn wir
haben das heute so gemacht hat auch ein
youtube kanal ist in der beschreibung
verlinkt wenn ihr sehen wollt wie er
fährt in seinem auto den banken bisschen
durch die gegend hier prügeln sich harte
beifahrersitz bin und nicht fleisch dann
schaut in der beschreibung vorbei ist
ein kanal verlinkt was ihn gern aber da
und ja einfach irgendwas geht der fang
jetzt sind wir genau hier drauf drücken
und dann zurück jedoch drücken und dann
und dann nochmal da geht es aber richtig
das rückgang hier das kann manchmal kurz
zeigen heute besser übersät aber das ist
halt so ein ding also muss sagen fühlt
sich gut an alles hier
ich hatte echt gedacht dass so dass ich
jetzt von mir nicht so krass verarbeitet
vielleicht haben es sehr schön hier
wirklich geil katharina aber die kamera
die auflösung ist halt aber es gibt
einfach noch was schlimmeres
und so dass sie da durch muss ersten
thema hat und jetzt das die maps macht
das ja ich hier steht das ist das
schlimmste was es gibt nein einfach nein
klassiker also leute das auto
beschleunigt
[Musik]
manual
oder du kannst hier darauf der mann der
automat egal das auto das also ist
richtig richtig roh alter weiter gerade
eben schon das ist wie sowieso ein
militärisches produkt leute das ist so
weil dazu gebaut und der der entwickler
der hat sich ja weißt du was mir ist es
scheißegal ob das ding irgendwie nicht
so super poliert ist und nicht so paar
ruhige und ausgereift hauptsache action
einfach so als ob der ladedruck und geil
aber ultraleichte lenkung fühlt sich
sehr sehr agil an das auto obwohl es 1,8
tonnen wie gut man merkt aber auch schon
die masse dann doch ne ersten moment
denkst du dass ein fliegengewicht da war
das was man hier auf jeden fall auch
stört ist wenn du schaltest ziemlich
eine haut die gänge ich dran bin ich
gespannt wirklich unser militär sport
war gesetzt dieses komplette elektro
einfach
[Musik]
ein bisschen anstellen der ball aber
nicht
also klopp macht er nicht
[Musik]
das ist geil
das ist geil aber ich muss aus dem
manuellen modus rost das ist doch zu
viel
ja geil die hälfte ist heftig heftig
heftig ist wirklich
[Musik]
geil digger
o
[Musik]
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil digger ist ja
im radio schon gesehen der hat so eine
art von turboloch auch na ja auf jeden
fall hätten also ordentlich das
turboloch der braune ordentliche
gedenksekunde bis es losgeht aber dann
alles wie beim lambo meinte auswahl am
bus und weiter das hier ist auch das hat
eigentlich nicht diese krasse fighter
jet optik soll das fühlt sich so an so
poliert weist das ist richtig einfach
hat zum beschleunigung ist dass er halt
ein monster safe gegensatz zum
lamborghini zum saugmotor schiebt er
jetzt schon mal ganz normal auf jeden
fall der so ein super della monica alles
arbeiten megageil der autobahnauffahrt
leute ist komplett frei von uns hinter
uns lassen alles im blick launch control
machen wir nicht bei dem auto weil man
weiß so ungefähr das launch control nur
viel genau das getriebe ist ein bisschen
anfangs control deswegen einfach schnell
ist anfang ja nicht anfahren bremsen
forderten und dann die gedenksekunde wo
jetzt der booster
[Musik]
die scheinheilige sind geil finde ich
gar nicht so brutal und schnell kannst
du gas geben
180 190 2 oder hinterher schiebt geil
ist geil digger geiles auto und kann ich
gut verstehen dass leute sich dafür
begeistern muss ich sagen das ist
richtig wild einfach das lodge ist
wirklich so geil digger
du gibst du vollgas fast gar nichts am
anfang und dann diese gedenkt sie könnte
weiß okay jetzt immer durch ab und
gleich gleich haut er mir eine rein und
dann kommt der bus das klingt auch mega
geil es liegt so schwachsinnig wenn der
so schreit
ja geil spiele der respekt
heute hat das recht
ja so viel
[Musik]
230 und das lange nicht schluss gemacht
ich glaub das höchste was ich gefahren
bin hat er 120 ja aber ich glaube der
stoff noch ein bisschen mehr ist nicht
abgeregelte viele regel haben also die
fahranfänger sind und dann wenn man
fortgeschritten ist er kann dinge so
krank dass zu verrückt sowieso ein
superstar der schiebt einfach
wunderschöne finde ich bei dem auto ist
auch dass sie halt alles sie ist schnell
du fährst schon weit fahren dann
ladedruck erst dass ihre direkt an sich
also gefällt mir sehr gut
richtig schön einfach bandana man
wirklich leute müssten drin sitzen wir
hier gas gibt das auto ist in das macht
irgendwas also wenn ihr dann noch im
stage 2
selbst drei master bisher komplett geist
krank das bisschen gemacht wir noch
zweiten messe meister so macht bestehen
wollen jetzt forscher freien galla
die gäste konnten
242 nicht ganz schafft modus ist auch
schon haben wir arbeiten jetzt
bedingungen jetzt nicht ob die mehr klar
wir sind im modus jetzt geht es jetzt
gilt's leicht bergab dann folgt wieder
leicht bergauf
ja er hat die gedenkt die kulisse
erste frage was macht man damit diese
anfängliche
das tor
ja
bremsen habe ich habe mich auch gerade
auf euch schwer sich zu dem christa ein
bisserl auf zur zweiten natur und jetzt
kommen noch nicht wir haben es einfach
nicht geschafft passable zeiten
rauszuhauen leute aber kommen wir jetzt
direkt zur bewertung denn das auto
könnte euch mit seinem app store sehr
sehr sehr überraschend kommen wir zum
aussehen ganz klar für mich dass hier
viele viele punkte fällig sind das heck
ist unfassbar schön von vorne hat
erwarten nicht ganz mein geschmack
getroffen aber im profil und von hinten
oben ein gott von hinten einfach krank
acht von zehn die beschleunigung ist
über jeden zweifel erhaben 2,8 sekunden
angegeben null auf hundert ist nur zehn
von zehn gar keine frage auch bei der
coolen ist kann der wagen punkt leute
dass es für jeden der fast and furious
geschaut hat einfach ein killer auto und
das hat einfach tradition es ist einfach
es sind cooles auto man kann nicht sagen
dass das kein cooles auto ist es ist
einfach geil und noch cooler macht das
auto für mich dass man damit keine die
laras abschleppen kann zeigt wenn man
sich das fort und so viel bezahlt ist
man wirklich einfach ein reiner kg acht
von zehn die praktikabilität ist
natürlich typischerweise bei
supersportwagen wieder geht er einer ist
nicht allzu ausgeprägt ladekante beim
kofferraum ist sehr hoch die rücksitze
kann zu vergessen spritverbrauch ist
natürlich auch sehr hoch aber man muss
sagen das ist noch okay finde ich fand
das auto man kann da gut einsteigen dass
es nicht klein das ist okay 15 daran die
preis-leistung leute eine der stärksten
kategorien des nissan gt r der kostet
nur in anführungszeichen knapp über
100.000 euro für den supersportwagen mit
570 ps er in unter drei sekunden von
null auf hundert geht das sind
bombastische werte für den preis nichts
spezielles auto ist sogar noch besser
weil er sich dann als jahreswagen geholt
das heißt hat noch mal geld gespart
hammer preis leistungsverhältnis acht
von zehn zuletzt vor gut klar ich meine
das ding ist auch irgendwo ein bisschen
härter so aber die stühle also die sitze
die nick darin hatte die bahn noch sehr
komfortabel am wirklich den wagen sehr
sehr sehr gut handelbar gemacht hätte da
auch kein problem damit 200 300
kilometer zu fahren fünf von zehn ist
absolut fair und alle die jetzt gut im
kopfrechnen sind habe es vielleicht noch
zusammen gezählt insgesamt kommt der
nissan gt r auf 44 von 60 punkten und
damit auf platz zwei in der allzeit ich
teste wertung nur noch geschlagen von
remys angeht 463 s wahnsinns punktestand
wahnsinns auto
einfach geil bis nächste woche leute